de vous installer
ce qui est fait mais aussi voilà de
faire un peu silence merci
en septembre oui sinon son tour voilà
c'est ce qui est le cas d'ailleurs parce
que je vous rappelle que nous sommes
enregistrés
allez on va commencer vous souvenez mes
chers collègues quand en
7 vous souvenez quand septembre dernier
le bureau de la commission
à souhaiter confier à nos collègues
Jérémy Baki Céline boulet peronnier et
Sonia de la pauvreté une mission de
contrôle sur la situation de la filière
cinématographique en France c'est dans
le cadre des travaux de cette mission
que nous avons le plaisir de recevoir ce
matin Monsieur Jérôme Seydoux qu'au
président du groupe Pathé et Monsieur
ERDA Vans ça fait président de patefilm
que je remercie évidemment en votre nom
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
monsieur sedoux vous êtes en effet un
homme qui compte comme on dit dans le
cinéma français européen et vous est
disposez également d'une voie qui porte
bien au-delà du milieu du septième art
surtout lorsque vous affirmez que je
vous cite le public ne vient pas en
salle parce que les films qui sortent ne
sont pas bons ou également que les
cinémas français doivent se défaire de
ses dogmes votre engagement dans le
secteur du cinéma date de 1990 année au
cours de laquelle vous rachetez
l'historique société Pathé fondée en
1896 et je ne peux pas empêcher de
rappeler qu'elle a été fondée à
Vincennes vous en avez été le PDG
jusqu'en 2000 puis président du conseil
de surveillance entre 2000 et 2002
depuis cette date vous exercez les
fonctions de co-président de Pathé en
2017 vous avez racheté à votre frère
sépare dans les salles de la société
Gaumont le groupe réalise aujourd'hui un
chiffre d'affaires de près d'un milliard
d'euros et emplois 5000 salariés Pathé
Gaumont et de loin le premier exploitant
en France avec le quart des entrées en
2019 et 14 du parc national mais le
groupe Pathé est aujourd'hui présent à
toutes les étapes de la chaîne du cinéma
vous intervenez au niveau de la
production de films de leur distribution
en salle et en vidéo et mené par
ailleurs une action de restauration des
films anciens et gérer un catalogue de
plus de 800 longs métrages votre parole
est rare et quand elle s'exprime elle
est entendue répétée qu'en témoigne
l'écho reçu par les déclarations que
j'évoquais à l'instant nous allons donc
l'écouter avec une particulière
attention
je vous propose de vous donner les
paroles pour une dizaine de minutes afin
que vous puissiez nous faire partager à
la lumière de votre expérience votre
vision du cinéma français et de sa place
dans un environnement marqué par
l'arrivée évidemment des plateformes
puis je passerai successivement la
parole à aux trois rapporteurs de notre
mission de contrôle et enfin l'ensemble
des sénatrices et sénateurs qui
souhaitent s'exprimer après avoir
rappelé que cette audition est captée
est diffusée sur le site internet du
Sénat je vous donne à présent monsieur
Seydoux la parole
merci beaucoup
bonjour tout le monde
on est très heureux ardavre et moi
d'être ici et de vous expliquer un peu
ce qu'on pense du cinéma alors d'abord
un mot pour dire que le cinéma sort
d'une période qui a été très difficile
les salles de cinéma ont été fermées la
plupart du temps en 2020 et en 2021 et
l'année 2022 a été une année de
convalescence donc on sort d'une période
très difficile et dans cette période
très difficile
Pathé c'est disons adapté on a fait des
gros efforts de s'adapter à une forme
d'une nouvelle donne la nouvelle donne
elle vient fondamentalement de
l'évolution si vous voulez du monde
digital aujourd'hui le monde digital se
développe partout et il a son influence
dans le cinéma comme ailleurs alors ce
monde digital il a plusieurs formes il
évidemment la forme des plateformes les
plateformes qui existaient évidemment
avant le covid mais le covid a été une
période très favorable aux plateformes
et très défavorable au sein de cinéma et
même défavorable au tournage de films
donc la période où sortons d'une période
difficile et cette période difficile à
entraîne des modifications alors quelles
sont ces modifications les modifications
c'est que les gens ont pris l'habitude
de regarder des films à travers les
plateformes ou la télévision
traditionnelle ils ont un choix énorme
ils ont une qualité excellente et ils
ont des prix qui sont bas parce que les
plateformes c'est pas cher si on regarde
le ce qu'on paye par mois ce n'est pas
cher donc nous avons à faire face à une
évolution de notre environnement et est
Pathé face à cette évolution après des
décisions qu'on avait d'ailleurs pris
avant le covid mais du sens qu'on
appelle la montée en gamme c'est-à-dire
que à la fois que ça soit du côté des
films ou du côté des salles du côté des
salles ça veut dire plus de confort plus
de spectacles et du côté des films ça
veut dire des films qui sont
indiscutables pour le spectateur parce
que le spectateur aujourd'hui comme il a
une formidable chez lui il faut lui
donner des raisons pour aller en salle
et les raisons pour aller en salle c'est
que il faut que ce soit un film qu'il
est vraiment envie de voir il faut que
ça soit dans un endroit où il a vraiment
envie d'aller donc voilà où nous allons
on sera tout à fait prêt de répondre à
toutes vos questions mais
fondamentalement nous on considère que
le métier que nous faisons faire des
films distribuer des films
exploiter des salles est un métier qui
restera demain qui ne va pas disparaître
parce que c'est la seule offre véritable
en face des plateformes donc le voir un
film en commun voir un film avec
d'autres gens voir un spectacle qui est
différent de ce qu'on peut voir chez soi
ça va perdurer mais ça ne perdurera que
si on est si on fait une offre qui est
bonne bon alors comme je sais que
vous intéressez fondamentalement
peut-être plus au film gros sale mais
Pathé c'est 85% du chiffre d'affaires
dans l'exploitation de ça les 15% pour
les films donc le le nous vivons si nous
si nous vivons demain et si on peut
vivre c'est quand même les salles qui
font vivre la société alors les films
sont indispensables parce que de ça sans
fil il y a pas il y a pas de spectacle
et des films qui on aurait pas de ça ça
ne marche pas pas non plus épaté est une
société qui n'est que dans le cinéma on
est on a démarré un peu une activité de
série la série c'est pas du cinéma mais
fondamentalement notre métier c'est le
cinéma alors moi je voudrais passer la
parole
d'avant pour qui vous explique plus quel
est un peu la position et de pâté et de
dire un peu ce qu'il pense
du film français et et de son et de sa
capacité à séduire non seulement les
Français mais également les étrangers
merci
merci de nous recevoir et nous donner la
parole très heureux de pouvoir exprimer
devant vous aujourd'hui parce que
les films aussi le cinéma en général
transmet beaucoup de fantasmes et notre
métier est souvent méconnu et j'aimerais
profiter de cette cette prise de parole
pour vous expliquer un peu plus comment
on fonctionne mais c'est vrai que sur
les films on a connu j'en me souviens de
le dire aussi une crise très très grave
la société en général
et il y a des ce qui a profondément
changé pour rappeler un peu les propos
de Jean pseudo aussi il y a quelques
années
les pour voir un film les gens devaient
soit aller en salle de cinéma soit
acheter un DVD je m'explique il y a
quelques il y a encore pas si longtemps
il y avait ce qu'on appelle des jours
interdits à la télévision ne pouvait pas
diffuser de films de cinéma de nombreux
jours dans la semaine il n'y avait pas
de plateforme il n'y avait pas de ce
qu'on appelle de télévision de
rattrapage aujourd'hui il y a une offre
absolument démultipliée de films
disponibles pour les gens effectivement
à bas coût et ce n'est pas la le seul
moyen pour de pour les gens d'aller voir
des films ce n'est pas d'aller en salle
c'est aussi ils peuvent aussi rester
chez eux
donc nous avant le covid on avait déjà
commencé à cette réflexion sur comment
faire en sorte que les gens viennent
dans les salles de cinéma pour voir les
films et quel film il voulait voir
la première question qu'on s'est posée
c'est combien de films devons-nous nous
Pathé produire et distribués est-ce que
on a la capacité de soutenir financer
distribuer mettre en avant autant de
films c'est à dire on avait certaines
années 16 17 films à distribuer dans
l'année ce qui
parfois engendrer des difficultés
notamment de mise en avant de beaucoup
de films et on n'avait pas les moyens de
bien les travailler donc on sait déjà on
s'est dit faisons moins de films mais
faisons les mieux dans
la réflexion aujourd'hui pour tout le
monde je crois que c'est pas que Pathé
la réflexion aujourd'hui c'est
il y a eu un vieillissement de notre
audience de cinéma nos spectateurs
des films je parle toujours des films
français
et une concurrence très très forte des
plateformes sur notamment la partie plus
jeune de nos spectateurs et comment
aujourd'hui on peut faire en sorte de
faire revenir au cinéma mais c'est pas
que ça c'est dans l'économie des films
on parle toujours de la salle mais
l'économie des films elle se elle se
elle se compte elle se calcule sur de
nombreux médias et de nombreuses années
il y a la salle de cinéma il y a aussi
la vidéo et la vidéo c'est un secteur la
vidéo à l'acte je parle pas des
plateformes mais la vidéo qui sont un
secteur qui a perdu près d'un milliard
d'euros de marché depuis 10 ans
c'est la télévision donc on parle à la
fois des prêts achats dans les
financements mais également de la vie en
télévision après ces pré-acha là sur
parfois 10 15 20 ans voir 50 ans vous
pouvez encore voir des films à la
télévision qui ont plus de 50 ans et
c'est et on parle assez peu c'est
l'international
et dans notre réflexion sur les films
qu'on veut maintenant produire et
distribuer on a notre réflexion elle
porte sur la salle elle porte aussi
beaucoup sur l'international parce que
on ne peut plus se dire avec le monde
des plateformes qui elles ont créé
finalement des brèches dans dans les
frontières il y avait des frontières
très très fortes et très importantes
dans les financements des films français
parce qu'avant l'arrivée des plateformes
on travaillait en circuit interne avec
les chaînes françaises des partenaires
français uniquement et l'économie était
uniquement française aujourd'hui elle
est arrivée des plateformes un peu cassé
ces frontières nos films nos séries
peuvent voyager mais on voit aussi tous
les films des séries des autres pays
arrivés donc dans cet environnement là
si on ne réfléchit pas à comment nos
films peuvent être à la fois
on va dire bon pour les spectateurs en
France mais pas aussi s'exporter je
pense qu'on aura du mal à exister très
très longtemps
donc l'univers des plateformes
aujourd'hui a apporté beaucoup d'argent
dans le marché c'est le milliard dont je
parlais qu'on a perdu sur la vidéo à
l'axe vidéo et DVD et VOD a été remplacé
par en termes d'économie pure par les
plateformes mais ces plateformes
aujourd'hui investissent très peu dans
le cinéma français on a mis en place
effectivement avant le covid et pendant
le covid
des obligations
pour que les plateformes investissent
dans le cinéma comme le font les chaînes
françaises
mais aujourd'hui le principal financier
du signal français reste Canal+ qui de
par son la taille de son investissement
à une fenêtre exclusive avant tout le
monde
mais les plateformes elles ont décidé au
moment où les obligations sont mises en
place d'investir la majorité de leurs
obligations dans les séries et pas dans
le cinéma
c'était aussi lié au covid c'était Olié
au fait que nous il faut bien voir que
quand on était confiné quand on recevait
on lisait des dizaines d'articles chaque
semaine sur la mort du cinéma
donc dites vous qui ont été vraiment
dans un moment un peu difficile aussi
pour nous comment est-ce que demain qui
est arrivé ces plateformes là qui
montaient en gamme et qui faisait des
films de plus en plus ambitieux
aujourd'hui on voit des films qui
coûtent 100 200 millions de dollars sur
les petits qui sortent plus en
plateforme
merci plateformes sont aussi en train de
changer on a remarqué j'ai fait un
voyage récemment à Los Angeles pour
essayer de comprendre un petit peu
comment le marché américain fonctionnait
aujourd'hui on remarque d'une part dans
un marché qui n'est pas du tout régulé
où il n'y a aucune aide ou l'état
n'intervient pas
on ne voit que des films à 150 millions
de dollars ou plus les seuls projets de
cinéma qu'on voit là-bas ce sont ceux-là
ou des films des petits documentaires
des petits films à moins de 5 millions
et les plateformes elles pour le coup
sans régulation elles amènent beaucoup
d'argent pour les films c'est pas encore
notre cas en France il y a sans doute
quelque chose à changer pour les attirer
encore plus les oblige à mettre plus
d'argent dans le cinéma parce que on a
besoin de l'ensemble des acteurs
aujourd'hui qui c'est un acteur
important et heureusement qu'il est là
pour financer l'ensemble de ces films je
pense que demain il y a il faut que ces
plateformes qui
font beaucoup de chiffre d'affaires en
France puissent aussi à la hauteur de
leur de leur importance dans la Camille
française puissent investir dans le
cinéma français pour améliorer aussi
monter en gamme notre scène montée en
gamme qu'on qu'on
veut et qu'on souhaite et qu'on a fait
dans les salles de cinéma il faut aussi
qu'on la fasse dans les films
et les films récents on a travaillé que
ce soit Astérix c'est vraiment
mousquetaire le compte de Monte-Cristo
bientôt répondre à cette besoins de
monter en gamme et de spectacle mais
évidemment le cinéma en France et sa
spécificité et c'est ce de nous pays en
France un cinéma extrêmement envié c'est
la diversité des films qu'on a et cette
diversité là elle nous permet aussi à
nous de faire des gros films elle nous
permet aussi on a on a fait Astérix on a
aussi fait revoir Paris dans nos cours
le prochain film de Xavier Beauvoir les
films
et c'est cette diversité qui permet à la
fois de renouveler les talents de
renouveler la création et nous permettre
aussi de faire ces films spectaculaires
et ces films grand public qui permettent
aux gens de venir aussi en salle de
cinéma
merci messieurs pour ces premiers propos
qui éclaire bien la problématique je
vais sans plus tarder donner la parole à
nos rapporteurs en commençant par Jérémy
Baki merci merci messieurs pour vos
propos les mineurs j'aurais une seule
question en fin de laisser aussi mais
mes collègues au rapporteur pouvoir vous
poser d'autres questions monsieur
Seydoux vous évoquiez notamment le
modèle d'exploitation des salles et la
part réservée aux films dans dans
finalement le business plan de des
salles vous défendez de longue date une
sorte de stratégie de premiumisation
finalement de vos salles ainsi le prix
de biais de certaines des salles je
pense notamment aux selles parisiennes
par exemple Beaugrenelle ou au Nouveau
Cinéma Parnasse dépasse les 20 euros de
prix le billet bien sûr il s'agit là de
cas très particuliers qui nous reflète
pas le prix moyen du billet en France
aux alentours de 7 euros avec des
équipements de très haut niveau
disons-le et y compris un confort
inégalé au niveau des salles ma question
est relativement simple c'est ne
craignez-vous pas qu'à un moment donné
le cinéma puisse rompre avec le
caractère populaire et comment vous
arrivez à concilier à la fois quelque
chose de grand public qui reste
populaire et une sorte de prémonisation
dont on parlait tout à l'heure puisque
je note en effet que la France et ce
singularis peut-être très fortement des
autres pays européennes et aussi
mondiaux sur la permanence du cinéma en
tant que grande sortie populaire et
souvent familiale dans ce pays c'est
vraiment un marqueur essentiel voilà ça
sera ma seule question et
je me doute bien mais j'attaque de suite
vous êtes pas venu pour rien
j'attendais mais vous savez quand on est
quand on dirige une entreprise
il y a deux choses qui sont importantes
un il faut que les clients soient
satisfaits et deux il faut que
l'entreprise fonctionne ce sont deux
choses absolument fondamentales alors je
vais répondre de manière très très
simple ce qui marche le mieux chez Pathé
aujourd'hui ce sont les salles premium
le aujourd'hui quand vous allez au
cinéma vous allez au cinéma réservant
votre place vous la réservez en avance
quand il y a un film qui est qui est
demandé les places qui partent en
premier
réservation sont les places les plus
chères
donc je sais pas si ça répond à votre
question mais ce que je veux dire je
veux dire une deuxième chose qui est
très importante c'est que le cinéma mon
marché c'est la télévision aujourd'hui
si vous voulez il y a une époque moi
quand je suis un gamin quand je suis un
étudiant voir des films il n'y a que le
cinéma il n'y a rien d'autre la
télévision n'existe pas et les cinémas
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
sont à la fois très chers la première
exclusivité et le prix descend au fur à
mesure qu'on s'éloigne de la date de
sortie du film Les Films sortaient
première exclusivité deuxième
exclusivité troisième exclusivité et
finissez par aboutir en plus on voyait
après sa défi qui était ancien et
suivant la date de naissance du film le
prix diminuait bon mais il n'y avait que
le cinéma donc le cinéma était adressait
forcément à tous les gens qui vouloir
des images mais aujourd'hui si vous
voulez le cinéma pas cher le cinéma pas
cher c'est la télévision il faut il faut
pas il faut pas se tromper c'est notre
concurrent principal et si nous voulons
concurrencer la télévision sur le prix
nous avons perdu parce que la télévision
elle est ou gratuite ou même les
plateformes c'est pas cher c'est c'est
10 euros 12 euros par mois donc le très
rapidement pour toute une famille donc
on peut pas concurrencer le le les gens
iront au cinéma parce que c'est une
sortie parce qu'ils vont passer un bon
moment et ce qu'ils veulent c'est qu'on
leur offre du confort des bons films et
un bon moment donc il y a on peut tout à
fait avoir une théorie de dire on va
faire du cinéma low cost moi je n'y
crois pas moi je n'y crois pas et je
crois que ce que les spectacles veulent
ils veulent si on va au cinéma on veut
passer un bon moment voilà
c'est niveau ni moi ni personne qui
décide c'est le spectateur qui décide
parce que si nos prix sont trop chers et
ils n'iront pas si les gens viennent pas
on fera autre chose alors merci pour la
franchise de votre album j'allais dire
j'attendais la question je n'attendais
je n'entendais pas moins de votre part
non mais c'est notre responsabilité si
vous voulez de de chef d'entreprise mais
je vais même vous pousser plus loin
aujourd'hui si vous voulez en début
d'année sortie d'une période très
difficile la société de cinéma de salle
qui marche le mieux en France c'est nous
voilà
bon mais merci juste pour préciser
peut-être un peu la question et après
j'essaierai la parole réellement à à mes
cours à porter
pour le coup vous disiez à juste titre
c'est le spectateur qui décide en
réalité quelque part alors pensez-vous
que ce qui se fait dans quelques sales
parisiennes est exportable sur
l'ensemble du territoire national et
aurait les mêmes effets que ce qu'on
peut vivre sur certaines salles
parisiennes ou est-ce qu'on doit voir
continuer
l'existence finalement de deux offres
différenciées avec des salles pour le
coup premium pour un certain public et
des salles peut-être un peu moins
confort mais qui fonctionnerait plus
dans un phénomène de massification voilà
alors faut voir les proportions
aujourd'hui en France Pathé en gros que
je dise pas de maison doivent en gros
700 salle
les salles premium on la sent voilà donc
c'est sans salle sur 700 bon maintenant
il existe aussi l'abonnement il existe
l'abonnement l'abonnement fait que si
vous êtes abonné vous arrivez si vous
êtes vraiment quelqu'un que vous allez
très souvent vous abonner et votre prix
de revient la place du cinéma sera
infiniment plus faible
et puis il existe des vous pouvez
acheter il y a tout autre manière le
prix je vous dire parce qu'on vous met
toujours le prix principal dans nos
recettes le prix les gens qui payent le
prix fort c'est 20% des clients c'est
20% des clients parce qu'il y a aussi il
y a les abonnements il y a les ventes
qu'on fait au comité d'entreprise etc
donc il y a des d'autres formes de vente
qui font que le prix moyen n'est pas le
prix mais les gens ils veulent le
premier je peux que vous je ne peux que
vous dire ça alors ce n'est pas une
originalité française
c'est une évolution mondiale
le on regarde toujours si on regarde nos
collègues ce que nous voulons nous et en
gros il évolution de la plupart des
groupes de salles de cinéma du monde
et ce qui est le plus demandé c'est le
siège très confortable
deuxième question de
Sonia de la probauté quelque chose me
dit que vous vous attendez aussi à celle
à cette question mais je vais laisser
former
[Rires]
je vais revenir sur votre déclaration
bien connue du 12 octobre sur France
Inter vous avez déclaré je vous cite les
gens ne veulent pas aller au cinéma pour
se faire chier je souscris tout à fait à
cette à cette remarque en même temps une
des questions principales hormis le
confort de la salle et quand même
qu'est-ce qui fait venir les gens au
cinéma est-ce que c'est que pour passer
un bon moment comme vous l'avez dit où
est-ce que la question est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça puisqu'on a vu une
baisse de fréquentation du public
notamment le public des cinéphiles et
on passe un bon moment mais c'est un peu
plus comment dire c'est un peu moins
trivial ce qu'on peut ressentir quand on
vient sur un film qui vous interroge qui
vous qui vous fait réfléchir qui vous
fait qui vous fait vivre une expérience
qui certes est bonne mais parfois pas
forcément mais qui vous a apporté
quelque chose voilà donc je voulais vous
interroger sur cette il y a une deuxième
question donc je vais anticiper parce
que je vois bien que vous êtes prêts à
répondre et donc au delà de la tournure
volontairement polémique donc vous avez
mis vraiment un doigt le doigt sur un
aspect qui est au cœur de nos réflexions
et parmi ces réflexions il y a le nombre
et la qualité des films et ça c'est un
vrai sujet vous l'avez un peu abordé
tout à l'heure dans vos propos
liminaires pour schématiser d'un côté
une partie de la profession des fonds un
modèle censé préserver la liberté des
créateurs la diversité l'exception
culturelle qu'on remet très
régulièrement en avant et qui peut quand
même largement être un objet de fierté
quelque part ce qui revient à produire
et à donner
à un maximum d'oeuvre la possibilité de
trouver un public la possibilité c'est
c'est toujours cette grande question de
l'autre certains estiment que le cinéma
français est par nature trop nataliste
et il y a quand même tout un mouvement
autour de ça et on voit bien qu'à un
moment voilà la manne financière elle
trouve ses limites et devrait concentrer
les moyens sur des projets avec de
meilleures perspectives que pouvez-vous
dire à ce propos et comme
envisageriez-vous une régulation du
système de financement plus favorable
à vos vues ou en tout cas ce que vous
vous en pensez pensez vous qu'il existe
un bon nombre de films à produire chaque
année en France même si cette question
est quand même très complexe mais est-ce
qu'il faut avoir finalement des
objectifs par exemple plutôt objectif
premier second film pour vraiment voilà
créer l'émergence et puis après aller
sur des sur des plus grosses opérations
et en tout cas le vraiment le sujet
c'est le sujet de la concentration qui
est pas forcément ce qu'on cherche à
défendre dans le cinéma avec quelques
réalisateurs la tentation du blockbuster
ou
du de l'acteur bancable et et vraiment
comment on arrive à concilier les deux
sans se sont tués finalement le système
ou en tout cas voulu faire perdre de sa
qualité je vous remercie
d'abord la France n'a pas que le pâté il
y a d'autres opérateurs qui ont d'autres
opinions
qui défendent éventuellement d'autres
stratégies et
je pense que la France a beaucoup de
chance sur deux points de vue un parc de
salles qui est très diversifié parce que
nous on
est catalogué comme cinéma commercial
mais il existe aussi des cinémas arts et
c'est des cinémas de ville de de village
qui sont d'ailleurs presque toujours
subventionnés donc la France est quand
même au point de vue cinéma très bien
équipé
je pense qu'on est pas loin d'être un
des pays les mieux équipés au monde de
ce point de vue là la diversité existe
et ceux qui considèrent que ces Pathé
c'est trop cher ou que c'est pas des
films il veut aller ailleurs donc on
n'est pas de ce point de vue là bon
deuxièmement vous posez la question du
nombre de films c'est évidemment pas à
nous de répondre à cette question
arde avant a expliqué que de notre point
de vue du point de vue de la gestion de
l'entreprise nous allions nous
concentrer pour faire moins de films et
il se trouve qu'effectivement la France
produite beaucoup de films mais je pense
que véritablement s'il doit une
évolution et de de la réglementation
c'est au CNC qui vous posez la question
parce que c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
le CNC qui décide si vous voulez de
comment le nombre de films est quand
même lié au système de l'avant sur
recettes des subventions et ces
subventions sont peut-être pourraient
être donné d'une manière différente mais
c'est pas à nous oui c'est pas à nous de
répondre à cette question
il est il est toujours certain que si on
fait trop de choses à un avantage c'est
qu'on ouvre si des possibilités
peut-être à des gens qui ne feraient pas
de films
mais en ouvrant on a tendance à un peu à
saupoudrer et à son poudrer on est
éventuellement moins efficace donc si on
veut être plus efficace il faut
peut-être avoir des règles un peu plus
strictes sur la sélection des gens qui
reçoivent des subventions mais c'est pas
à nous oui c'est pas à nous de répondre
à cette question
c'est je pense d'une partie peut-être à
vous peut-être au CNC puis peut-être au
public mais je pense très réellement
qu'il y ait une évolution pour aller
aussi que les gens qui vont au cinéma
qui est une évolution qui aux États-Unis
depuis très longtemps c'est que qui
existait avant le covid c'est que aller
au cinéma par rapport à rester chez soi
à regarder télévision c'est un certain
effort et vous avez cité une phrase je
me reciterai pas moi-même parce que je
vais trouver j'avais peut-être été un
peu vulgaire ce jour-là mais
voilà donc
je pense que aller au cinéma qu'il
demande un certain effort on y va pour
son plaisir voilà même si quel que soit
le film on va voir alors ça peut être on
peut chercher à voir un film de grand
spectacle la France a une grande
réputation dans le film d'auteur et il y
a des gens qui ont envie de voir des
films d'auteur mais le film d'auteur
ou s'il faut qu'il atteigne un certain
niveau que les gens c'est les gens qui
décident oui si un film marche c'est pas
c'est pas le CNC c'est pas vous c'est
pas nous c'est le spectateur qui qui qui
finalement décide et le spectateur ça
lui arrive de se tromper mais il se
trompe pas tellement et quand un film ne
marche pas c'est rarement un film
excellent bon ça peut arriver mais c'est
très rare voilà donc la France est un
pays qui a défendu depuis toujours la
diversité du cinéma c'est une de ses
forces donc le le même si moi je peux
trouver quelques fois il y a trop de
films néanmoins je défendrai la
diversité c'est très important mais
diversité peut-être pas
peut-être peut-être mais il faut voir ça
que le CNC c'est le CNC qui a si vous
voulez qui décrète les aides
peut-être que c'est trop facile c'est
peut-être quelquefois trop facile de
faire un mauvais film
troisième question de notre
troisième rapporteur de
à la fois exploitant producteur
intéressant de vous entendre et moi
j'aurais donc trois questions
complémentaires la première c'est que
vous avez fait référence au rôle de
régulateur du CNC d'ailleurs à juste
titre mais est-ce que vous pensez que
l'activité de distribution des films
distribution pour être renforcée par
rapport à la production afin de donner
de meilleures chances au film
deuxièmement est-ce que vous seriez
favorable à un renforcement des
obligations de programmation en salle
afin d'éviter que les films
disparaissent trop vite ou que certaines
œuvres soient présentes sur trop d'écran
en même temps
et troisième question vous avez
récemment fait part de votre souhait
d'une entrée en bourse de pâté afin de
financer de nouveaux projets donc est-ce
que vous pourriez nous dire un peu plus
dans les détails les secteurs dans
lesquels vous souhaiteriez investir à ce
que ce sera les salles vous en avez déjà
un petit peu parlé la production etc
merci alors le investir c'est pas c'est
une question fondamentale dans n'importe
quel métier
si vous voulez rester
un peu au sommaire j'allais dire en top
un peu au sommet vous êtes obligé
d'investir tout le temps
on est dans un monde on est conduit par
le monde digital le digital le par
exemple nous nos dépenses digitales
elles vont augmenter tout le temps vous
voyez le
exemple aujourd'hui vous pouvez aller au
cinéma en réservant votre place sur le
téléphone vous allez avec votre
téléphone vous rentrez dans la salle bon
mais même cette application si on ne
passe pas notre temps à la perfectionner
sans arrêt on ne sera plus on ne sera
plus compétitif donc investir nous avons
l'obligation
d'investir tout le temps parce que c'est
ce qu'attend donc c'est ce qu'attendre
nos clients alors c'est c'est vrai pour
les salles mais c'est vrai pour
physiquement les salles mais c'est vrai
pour tout ce qui se voit pas nous sommes
tous dans un monde digital voilà donc
ceux qui ne sont pas passés qui n'ont
pas passé cette étape et ben il faut
qu'il rattrape voilà et je pense que si
Pathé a une avance sur ses confrères
français c'est le digital d'avance c'est
pas c'est pas tellement où le prix ou le
siège c'est sa véritablement ou on est
en avant alors
la bourse bon on verra bien oui je veux
dire le d'abord ce sera pas de main on
ne pourrait pas entrer en bourse
aujourd'hui sur des sur des résultats
d'une période qui a été très difficile à
20 à 21 22 donc il faut qu'on fasse une
bonne année en 23 et on verra en 24 si
le climat est favorable à ce genre de
choses donc aujourd'hui oui c'est un
projet mais il n'y a pas de de oui il y
a pas de il y a pas de certitudes
et une question j'ai parlé
alors l'obligation de programmation
moi je n'aime pas les obligations de
programmation je dis tout de suite je
pense que nous vivons de la diversité
donc la diversité elle est absolument
fondamentale pour la salle de cinéma
mais on ne peut pas forcer les gens
aller voir des films qui veulent pas
voir je veux dire et et il y a des films
qui sont produits en France qui ne
méritent pas la salle alors il y a une
chose qui en France qui est assez
compliqué qui devrait être changé
aujourd'hui un film de cinéma qui est
produit doit s'il a reçu des aides
publiques doit sortir en salle c'est une
obligation légale
cette obligation légale devrait être
changée parce qu'aujourd'hui un film n'a
pas qu'une vie en salle ils peuvent une
vie digitale plateforme télévision tout
ce qu'on veut et donc l'obligation de
sortir en salle c'est un ensemble parce
que la salle c'est quand même on va dire
c'est la partie prestigieuse de la
sortie d'un film mais il peut sortir sur
toutes les formes digitales qui existent
donc ce blocage réglementaire devrait
être changé donc la diversité oui les
obligations de programmées non parce que
c'est le spectateur qui décide qu'il a
envie de voir c'est pas si vous obligez
de dire je dois absolument mettre ce
film si les gens viennent pas moi je
peux vous raconter une anecdote que je
raconte toujours mais qui se passait il
y a très longtemps je visitais un des
premiers multiplexes de pâté et c'était
un samedi il y avait du monde et je dis
on peut pas voir les salles puisque sont
occupées
le film me plaît pas et le directeur me
répond mais monsieur même gratuitement
les gens viendraient pas donc on ne peut
pas forcer les gens veuillez avoir des
figues le bavoir donc la diversité oui
des obligations de programmées des films
que les gens veulent pas voir non
[Musique]
alors
c'était il y a très longtemps
donc vous n'étiez pas né voilà
et après
alors non mais c'était pas émettant en
scène inconnue et c'est un metteur en
scène qui a par la suite fait des films
qui ont tout à fait marcher
mais je donnerai pas son nom
je vous réponds aussi sur la votre
première question sur la distribution
[Musique]
il est évident que le maillon le plus
faible le plus fragile plutôt de la
chaîne c'est la distribution c'est même
plus fragile parce qu'il est
effectivement moins aidé mais parce que
c'est lui qui prend le plus de risques
de marché c'est-à-dire que c'est celui
qui prend le risque et son risque
l'argent qu'on investit pour financer le
film et pour aussi le faire exister ça
les frais de promotion de publicité
c'est frais augmente et c'est
investissements ne sont couverts on ne
serait couvert que par les revenus
issus de l'exploitation du film les
revenus en salle en vidéo à la
télévision internationale donc si le
film ne marche pas l'investissement est
perdu et si le film ne marche pas en
salle mais pas en vidéo il y a peu de
chance qui marche sur les autres médias
en télévision derrière donc c'est un
risque
donc c'est le maillon plus fragile
effectivement
les aides aujourd'hui à distribution il
y a des aides sélectives pour les
distributeurs indépendants et il y a des
aides automatiques et là d'automatique
sur la distribution elle est
essentiellement constituée de la du fond
de soutien distributeur qui a un maximum
d'environ 350 000 euros par film
c'est évidemment en temps d'échelle par
rapport à la production très très très
très très faible donc si on veut aider
aujourd'hui distributeur il faut bien
comprendre que pour distribuer un film
aujourd'hui dans les frais de promotion
de distribution faire exister un film
aujourd'hui c'est de plus en plus
difficile plus difficile de plus en plus
difficile de mettre en avant un film
parce qu'on on va investir énormément
juste avant la sortie
pour pour que les gens se disent c'est
ce film que je dois aller voir et pas un
autre il y a environ 15 SIM qui sort
chaque semaine les Américains ont
beaucoup plus de moyens que nous
publicité donc nous on profite aussi du
fait que de promotion les émissions on
peut faire venir les talents mais
globalement on n'a pas les mêmes moyens
que les autres et il faut qu'on soit de
plus en plus originaux de plus en plus
inventif créatif mais aussi qu'on ait
les moyens d'investir pour que ces films
existent si les scions ne savent pas que
le film existe mécaniquement ils iront
pas le voir
donc aujourd'hui les mécanismes les plus
efficaces qui existent
notamment en termes d'aide CNC c'est les
mécanismes dit automatique c'est ce qui
est très efficace pour la production
c'est ce qui permet aux producteurs
aujourd'hui d'avoir des fonds propres
pour investir dans le développement de
nos vies donc c'est très important
en revanche les distributeurs ne
bénéficient pas de cette de cette de
cette de cette dimension d'aide là et
donc n'ont pas les moyens de d'avoir des
fonds propres plus renforcés pour
investir et prendre des risques sur des
nouveaux films
s'il y avait un équilibrage qui
s'opérait de ce point de vue là sur les
automatiques ce serait sans doute
souhaitable
je vais prendre maintenant toute vos
questions vous demandant d'être
synthétiques
s'il vous plaît je vais commencer par
Julien barjetton
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président merci pour cette audition
c'est compliqué c'est parce que c'est
qu'un bon film un bon film qui marche je
me rappelle être avoir vu chez un
concurrent désolé le film everything
everywher at wants qui n'a pas fait un
énorme succès en France qui a raflé tous
les Oscars et pourtant quand je suis
allé le voir à côté là du Sénat il y
avait une salle à moitié vide pourtant
ça c'est un très très bon film donc
c'est vrai que un film parfois du temps
à démarrer maintenant il aura fait les
Oscars peut-être qu'il aura une deuxième
chance en tout cas je l'espère parce que
même s'il dure 2h20 c'est un film assez
prodigieux vous parlez beaucoup des
plateformes quand même elle rencontre un
certain nombre de difficultés Netflix
étant difficulté depuis quelques mois et
cherche des alternatives notamment avec
une offre désormais qui comprend la
publicité comme vous le savez qui a été
lancé il y a peu Disney est également en
grande difficulté puisqu'ils ont annoncé
des licenciements massifs dans le monde
en France et ailleurs et d'ailleurs je
crois que le PDG de la plateforme a été
licencié sauf erreur de ma part
Warner HBO hésite ils avaient prévu de
lancer leur plateforme et finalement ils
ne sont pas sûrs du tout de la Lancer et
du service qui vont proposer on le voit
la concurrence est très forte vous dites
qu'il y a peut-être trop de films la
question qu'on pourrait se poser c'est
est-ce qu'il y a trop de plateformes et
je compare un sujet que je connais un
peu qui est celui de la musique où il y
a évidemment une universalité de l'offre
puisque vous avez n'importe quel
plateforme et vous avez toute la musique
en ligne alors que pour voir toutes les
séries tous les films etc il faut
s'abonner à plusieurs à plusieurs
plateformes donc les investissements ont
peut-être été trop importants et
visiblement il y a une difficulté pour
rentabiliser en tout cas pour rencontrer
un nombre de consommateurs suffisant par
plateforme pour rentabiliser les
investissements de chacun alors comment
voyez-vous l'avenir de ce marché est-ce
que finalement ce ça va évoluer
puisque ce business model semble quand
même plus plus compliqué et vous lui
attribuez le fait qu'il y ait une baisse
de la fréquentation en salle sans doute
mais cette concurrence des plateformes a
aussi une une concurrence alors est-ce
que c'est une bulle est-ce que c'est une
menace persistante pour l'avenir et
est-ce que on doit s'attendre à des
recompositions c'est-à-dire par exemple
à une réduction du nombre de plateformes
est-ce que au fond on a une
stabilisation à ce stade de cette
concurrence entre nombre de plateformes
et film en sable merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le Président oui moi je
voulais revenir sur les crédits d'impôts
que j'ai abondamment
déposé pour pour qu'il soit en tout cas
poursuivi ça n'a pas été le cas lors du
dernier projet de loi de finance à
l'automne dernier et là on arrive au
pied du mur puisque on arrive au moment
de ces renouvellements parce que c'est
la fin des crédits d'impôts actuel à
partir de 2024 est-ce que vous pourriez
revenir dessus parce que bien évidemment
je vous ai dit que c'était pas nous qui
étions à convaincre mais plutôt nos
commissaires de la commission des
finances qui connaissent pas forcément
comment on produit un film et en effet
le même tout le travail des
distributeurs et s'il fallait entre
guillemets en choisir un ou deux qui
pourraient rassembler l'ensemble de la
profession qui serait le plus
fédérateur est-ce que vous auriez une
opinion là-dessus parce que peut-être
qu'on ne pourra pas tous les ravoirs
abondamment comme comme la dernière fois
ou avec la crise du CO vid en effet
Bercy avait été un peu plus généreux
merci alors je vais d'abord répondre
on va prendre toutes les questions
je vous rappellerai de façon les
questions vous inquiétez pas Pierre
Antoine Lévy
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
j'ai deux questions rapides vous avez
parlé d'introduction en Bourse
éventuellement en fonction des
conditions de marché mais en janvier
dernier vous avez signé Pathé assigné un
accord de partenariat avec une société
logicole pitcherz en vue de lever 100
millions d'euros est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un petit peu plus sur ce
partenariat et en quoi est-il novateur
pour le cinéma français et deuxième
question on a assisté récemment devant
les salles de cinéma quel que soit des
scènes de violence dans et devant les
salles au risque de faire fuir des
clientèle familiale qu'est-ce quelles
sont les mesures que vous avez pris pour
empêcher que ça se reproduise
bonjour donc vous avez
fait
disciplinés
donc j'ai bien écouté votre présentation
et vous avez donc pour objectif d'avoir
une réflexion vers l'international et
plutôt si j'ai bien compris des films
grand public mais pour vous
l'international c'est où est-ce que ce
sont les États-Unis l'Asie l'Europe etc
vous pouvez me préciser parce que je
pense que c'est pas le même profil de
spectateur et ma question subsidiaire
que pensez-vous de la chronologie des
médias
je suis prête à faire du cinéma tout
quand tu fais
Laurence Garnier
bonjour Laurence bonjour monsieur le
président
bonjour à tous juste une question
concernant les fréquentations des salles
de cinéma vous avez évoqué rapidement
monsieur le public vous n'avez pas dit
vieillissant mais dans les faits on sait
qu'on a une interrogation par rapport à
cela
le Pass Culture du gouvernement a été
mis en place il y a quelques années il
permet pour les jeunes qui ont 18 ans
d'accéder à 300 euros de biens et de
sortie culturelles une somme assez
conséquente même si les jeunes sont
moins présents au cinéma qui n'ont pu
l'être il semblerait que ça reste la
première activité culturelle de cette
classe d'âge donc ma question était de
savoir si il y a une efficacité du Pass
Culture dans la fréquentation des jeunes
dans les salles de cinéma ou s'ils
viennent autant qu'avant ni plus ni
moins mais en bénéficiant de l'apport
financier du Pass Culture
[Musique]
merci président
ma question sera un petit peu connexe
aussi au cinéma si vous le permettez
monsieur le Président c'est que dans
votre carrière vous avez commencé comme
un indice financier
et le monde de la finance n'a pas trop
de secret pour vous et puis un moment de
votre évolution professionnelle et c'est
une expression qui revient souvent chez
vous vous avez peut-être dans le cinéma
voulu faire rêver les gens et pouvoir
s'abstraire de cette société des fois un
peu lourde et pesante et bien évidemment
un homme avisé ça fera sourire mes
collègues mais vous avez investi
massivement dans le cinéma mais
également dans un sport qui m'est cher
qui est le football
puisque vous étiez puisque vous étiez au
conseil d'administration de l'Olympique
Lyonnais et pour ceux qui ont un petit
peu de mémoire c'est grâce à vous qu'on
doit la venue de Sony Anderson dans le
championnat de France qui reste quand
même un grand moment
voilà donc je faisais le parallèle pour
faire révéler les gens
quel parallèle faites-vous entre à mon
avis les grandes l'avenir qu'il y a au
cinéma français au football français
mais les difficultés qu'il traverse et
l'un et l'autre voyez-vous des points de
rapprochement ou en tout cas des
constantes dans l'évolution y compris du
rêve et du business
dernière question c'est d'Olivier Pacaud
merci monsieur le président
je terminerai par effectivement un
parallèle avec le football mais je
commence par je serai court
rassurez-vous je rebondis sur ce qu'a
dit Jérémy Baki et je voulais vous
remercier quand même pour la franchise
de vos propos de businessman vous
assumez tout à fait la stratégie du
premier minimisation
c'est dire que c'est comme ça que Pathé
fonctionne bien mais le cinéma à la base
c'est un art populaire et peut-être que
vous vous coupez entre guillemets d'une
partie de vos potentiels
[Musique]
spectateurs dans mon département de
l'Oise comme dans beaucoup de
départements il existe ce qu'on appelle
le ciné rural c'est une association qui
a passé un partenariat avec chez nous
plus d'une centaine de communes et qui
va donc régulièrement proposer des films
avec un petit peu de décalage
généralement c'est 3-4 semaines mais
c'est des places à 3 4 5 euros et la
famille peut venir bon c'est vraiment la
populaire par excellence
il y a aussi alors ça beaucoup disparu
mais quand on était un plus jeune moi
dans mon lycée il y avait un club ciné
bon il y avait des connexions qui
permettaient aux gens les plus modestes
d'aller vers le cinéma facilement
est-ce que vous avez quand même pas la
volonté ou vous avez pas eu des
réflexions pour aller quand même
conserver des liens avec ces gens que
vous ne touchez pas directement en
premier le foot c'est un bon exemple et
l'Olympique Lyonnais et peut-être le
meilleur exemple en France il a brillé
quand il avait beaucoup de sous et qu'il
pouvait attirer des stars mais il a
surtout brillé parce qu'il avait des
centres de formation et afin de
formation qui formait vraiment parmi les
meilleures joues allemandes Benzema il
est venu de là voilà donc il faut
ajuster équilibre peut-être et
évidemment j'ai aucune leçon à vous
donner puisque vous réussissez
parfaitement mais est-ce que en essayant
quand même d'avoir un lien avec ces gens
qui sont éloignés non seulement
géographiquement mais aussi
financièrement de l'accès à la première
mise à Sion ça serait pas pour vous
aussi une une voix de
développement quand même je sais pas si
j'ai été clair mais
on va reprendre des questions
dans l'ordre que vous voulez bien sûr il
y avait la première question sur les
plateformes est-ce que l'écosystème des
plateformes est stabilisé ou pas
alors malheureusement malheureusement
les plateformes sont toutes américaines
et donc l'évolution des plateformes
c'est pas la France qui va avoir une
influence sur l'évolution des
plateformes c'est le monde entier les
plateformes elles sont là pour durer y
a-t-il trop de plateformes peut-être
mais c'est pas nous on n'a pas
d'influence sur le savoir s'il y en aura
moins ou plus
on peut toujours quand on raisonne
généralement
quand on regarde c'est la télévision
l'évolution et aux États-Unis il y avait
il y avait trois grands network il y en
a eu un quatrième donc on peut penser
que dans le monde il y aura à terme 3 ou
4 plateformes voilà
dans les trois ou quatre on en connaît
déjà trois
Netflix Disney Amazon voilà ces trois là
et en France si on prend en France les
deux premières plateformes sont Netflix
et Amazon devant Canal+
elles ont plus de contacts chez les gens
que Canal+ donc c'est les les
Netflix et Amazon sont très très bien
implantés en France donc ils vont pas
disparaître
ils vont être là pour toutes les années
qui viennent bon il faut espérer que
canal sera résisté aux plateformes donc
voilà trois et puis il y aura peut-être
et puis on peut pas éliminer Apple etc
mais les plateformes elles vont pas
disparaître alors ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre aux États-Unis c'est qu'il y
a les plateformes que pendant le covid
les les médias américaines les grandes
maisons de production de films se sont
posés la question et ce qu'on va
continuer à sortir des films en salle où
est-ce qu'on va les sortir sur des
plateformes ils ont comme art d'avant il
a répondu tout à l'heure ils ont pris la
décision maintenant qui est très claire
que pour les films importants les films
sortaient d'abord en salle et il irait
ensuite sur les plateformes à part
Netflix qui gardent une stratégie un peu
différente c'est pour l'instant de ne
pas sortir ces films en gros en salle il
pourrait un jour changer d'avis mais
aujourd'hui c'est assez clair si vous
voulez pour notre environnement des
Américains n'ont pas abandonné la salle
ça c'est très très important voilà
deuxième question alors sur les crédits
d'impôts et s'il fallait hiérarchiser
les crédits d'impôts selon leur
importance par rapport à notamment
elle écosystème du cinéma lesquels sont
les plus essentiels pour vous
bon alors
il y a les fonds d'aide du CNC 13 ancien
qui sont l'aide automatique ou
les aides qui sont les aides les
aventures recettes bon
ça elles sont très anciennes je pense
pas qu'elles soient en danger ce qui est
relativement éventuellement danger c'est
le crédit d'impôts alors je là dessus
c'est très facile je voulais aujourd'hui
en avant à parler tout à l'heure nous
allons cette année nous avons 20 ans
produit au cours des années Astérix les
trois mousquetaires c'est des films qui
ont été tournés entièrement en France
c'est le premier Astérix tournait en
France les tous les autres Astérix sont
été tournés à l'étranger les trois
mousquetaires c'est le premier Alexandre
Dumas tourné en France depuis très
longtemps le dernier coup on est fait
chez Pathé qui était la reine Margot de
Patrice Giraud a été tourné au Portugal
donc le crédit d'impôt a Ener le
tournage
à ramener les tournages des films
importants en France ça c'est indéniable
et si demain le crédit d'impôt était
supprimé ces films où on ne les ferait
pas où il serait fait en dehors de
France ça c'est c'est absolument
indéniable donc le le si vous voulez
défendre le crise d'impôts c'est une
excellente idée et ça nous ferait très
plaisir
vous vous prêchez ici les convaincus
mais parfois les commissaires culture
peuvent être mis en minorité au sein
même du Sénat sur ce type de question
alors il y avait une autre question deux
autres questions de Pierre-Antoine Davy
sur le dernier partenariat vous avez
monté et puis aussi sur la façon de de
prendre les enfin les mesures que vous
pouvez prendre pour lutter contre la
violence mais ça sera dans les salles
mais à proximité
concernant le contrat avec logical
pictures vous parliez c'est un
effectivement une association à la
production et la distribution de nos
films de tous nos films qui seront en
fait qui sont en production depuis
l'année
20223 et 24 qui concerne on va dire à
peu près une cinquantaine de films mais
ça dépendra un petit peu des des
évolutions de la production et c'est un
partenariat qui implique un
investissement de leur part à côté de
nous un pourcentage de notre
investissement à nous et ceux ils sont
obligés d'investir sur tous nos films et
ce pourcentage il est
l'investisse dans tous nos films et le
récupère en fonction de leur
participation dans le film donc c'est un
partenaire stratégique qui apporte à
pâté la capacité de continuer à
développer justement des films ambitieux
sur le long terme puisque aujourd'hui
notre volonté c'est pas juste de faire
une année comme celle-ci mais de
régulièrement chaque année d'avoir des
films importants à proposer au public et
pour ça il faut il faut qu'on soit
soutenu et c'est cet apport de logical
picture nous permet de voir bien
l'avenir et de continuer à faire à
développer à faire ses films
la violence alors la violence
elle a toujours plus ou moins existé
dans les salles elle est liée elle est
liée au film et elle est très rare parce
que c'est pas le c'est très rare alors
évidemment c'est une question d'avoir
des services de sécurité mais le on ne
sait pas du tout on essaye de pas en
avoir mais certains films quelquefois
vous tombez sur des groupes est-ce que
vous faites
vous pouvez pas avoir une escouade de
CRS à la porte donc le vous faites face
et vous mais c'est franchement c'est
très rare franchement c'est très rare et
ça ne perturbe pas évidemment quand ça
se produit dans une salle c'est
excessivement désagréable et pour toute
l'équipe qui est là ces arbres mais une
équipe qui gère une salle de cinéma de
cinéma n'est pas elle n'est pas
entraînée à faire face à la violence
c'est pas son métier alors il y avait
deux questions de Monique de Marco la
première sur les marchés à l'export
quels sont les zones géographiques que
vous visez en priorité vous parlez de
l'international les les
territoires les pays qui achètent le
plus de cinéma français ça reste
l'Europe maintenant quand je parlais
dans un tout à l'heure c'était aussi
pour dire que des films justement comme
Astérix promoteur mais aussi de Dany
Boon d'Albert Dupontel le film d'Alice
vinocourt tous ces films là sont des
films qui attirent un public étranger
donc
on travaille sur ces films et la
rentabilité on parle souvent de ça mais
le l'international est un point
important comme être sur les trois
mousquetaires ou Astérix il y a des
publics très importants en Amérique
latine par exemple
en Allemagne c'est Astérix c'était une
marque quasiment aussi connue qu'ici en
Italie en Espagne dans tous les pays
européens en Asie également donc le ces
films là bénéficient d'un attrait du
public international et vite
effectivement
le marché le plus difficile pour nous
c'est les États-Unis et de manière
générale les marchés les plus difficiles
c'est les territoires qui ont en langue
anglaise Etats-Unis Angleterre Australie
pourquoi parce que aux États-Unis
particulièrement dès qu'on parle d'un
film qui n'est pas en langue anglaise
pour eux c'est un tout petit film donc
quel que soit quand on fait bien quand
on fait des films spectaculaires les
jeunes qui vont voir ses films aux
États-Unis ne veulent pas avoir des
films qui sont pas américains donc on a
des difficultés pour l'instant avec des
États-Unis mais c'est à nous si on
essaie d'y travailler également et notre
ambition si on arrive à faire en sorte
que ces films fonctionnent oui compris
dans les salles en France c'est pourquoi
pas de faire des films en langue
anglaise pas tous nos films un ou deux
films dans l'année qui puisse s'exporter
et puisse aussi
pourquoi pas fonctionner aux États-Unis
la question sur la chronologie des
médias est-ce que il faut continuer de
se battre pour le respect de la
chronologie des médias
[Musique]
de moderniser la chronologie des médias
moderniser c'est à dire de donner un peu
plus de place aux plateformes
les plateformes auront plus de place si
les investissent plus d'argent c'est
c'est tout la difficulté donc c'est
moderniser ça veut dire assouplir les
règles pour que on s'adapte à chaque
film donc il faut il faut faire
attention à ce que les règles ne soient
pas trop strictes il faut il faut des
règles extrêmement claires pour que les
financements les films français
continuent d'être important mais il faut
qu'il y ait une certaine souplesse
aujourd'hui des chaînes et les
plateformes ont peut-être envie de
travailler ensemble
pour investir dans les films ensemble
donc faut leur permettre aussi des des
assouplissements de la chronologie pour
qu'ils puissent le faire tout ça au
bénéfice toujours du film
la question d'orange Garnier sur
l'efficacité du Pass Culture par rapport
évidemment aux jeunes et leur retour en
salle alors très efficace
si vous voulez l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles à la fin du covid notre
nombre d'abonnés et et non seulement est
remonter
aux chiffres de 2019 mais la même
dépassé la raison principale c'est le
Pass Culture donc le Pass Culture a été
en ce qui nous concerne sur les
abonnements cinéma extrêmement efficace
et enfin il y avait les deux questions
de vraiment hugonnets et d'Olivier
Pacaud sur le parallèle avec l'autre
monde que vous connaissez bien celui du
foot et le caractère à la fois populaire
enfin le lien entre maintenir le
caractère populaire et évidemment la
dimension économique et financière
croissante également dans le monde des
foot alors c'est pas alors nous ne
sommes plus dans la apicionaire on a on
a vendu notre participation à la fin
d'année dernière
mais on a été partenaire pendant
quasiment 25 ans alors il y a tout à
fait un parallèle
quand on a quand on a collaboré pour le
stade à Lyon
on s'est dit c'est
démultiplexe en une fois donc le tout à
fait des points communs on peut dire si
vous voulez les joueurs sont les
artistes dans les films on a des
comédiens etc
dans les deux cas il y a des agents
ils sont plus ou moins
gentils
et plus ou moins voilà compétent et
il y a un point qui est tout à fait
commun c'est que c'est du spectacle le
football professionnel c'est avant tout
un spectacle donc il y a tout à fait il
y a tout à fait des points communs il y
en a un sur lequel vous serez pas
tellement à l'aise c'est que la place de
football c'est plus cher que le cinéma
donc
voilà
mais je voulais revenir sur le prix si
vous voulez
et
sur les prix bon d'abord il y a des
fenêtres ouvertes
où le prix est bon marché vous avez à
partir du 19 mars le Printemps du Cinéma
à 5 euros partout
donc il y a quand même des
occasions ou et puis comme disait
monsieur il y a d'autres organisations
qui se concentre sur le prix le je pense
que dans quel que soit les métiers oui
même dans la boulangerie le prix du pain
n'est pas le même partout
et la place de cinéma n'est pas le même
partout et chacun peut suivre des voies
différentes mais par rapport à notre
jeunesse ou le cinéma était sans
concurrent aujourd'hui non seulement il
allait les concurrents de la télévision
des plateformes mais il a aussi le
téléphone les réseaux sociaux etc les
jeunes par exemple on dit la é des
vision mais les jeunes ne regardent pas
la télévision il ne regarde pas la
télévision ils ont éventuellement au
cinéma mais ils sont sur les réseaux
sociaux avec leur téléphone avec leur
ordinateur donc le monde a changé et
nous devons nous adapter à ce monde qui
a changé et ça sera c'est vrai
aujourd'hui et ça sera encore vrai
demain
merci Monsieur Seydou
réponse et la franchise de vos propos
qui fait toujours plaisir à entendre
quand les propos sont directs ils sont
d'autant plus audibles merci beaucoup
d'avoir
[Musique]
mes chers
de Bernard phillaire sur la fraude
artistique je vais raccompagner